Ayatollah Khamenei, the supreme leader
of Iran and all around evil terrorist
scumbag whose tentacles reached around
the world into the rear ends of puppet
groups like Hezbollah and Hamas, and who
recently slaughtered thousands of his
own people for protesting his demonic
regime, was killed in a series of
missile strikes by the United States and
Israel. Ironic, since he loved reciting
the mantras "Death to America" and
"Death to Israel" more than he loved
reciting the Shahada.
Khamenei's assassination has led to
endless tantrums on social media, but
even if you've been following the
hysterics, you probably have no clue how
devastating this is to Muslims, both to
Sunnis and Shias.
It's almost impossible to overstate how
traumatic the assassination of Khamenei
is to Muslims, but as usual, everyone is
completely missing the big picture. So,
I'm going to break down a few important
ideas in Islam and a little bit of
forgotten history, and when we put it
all together with what's going on in
Iran,
you'll understand why the avalanche of
apostasy is about to accelerate until it
absolutely buries Islam.
First important idea, Muslims are
superior to non-Muslims.
In Sura 98, verse 6 of the Quran, Allah
declares,
"Verily, those who disbelieve in the
religion of Islam, the Quran, and
Prophet Muhammad, from among the people
of the scripture, Jews and Christians,
and Al-Mushrikun, Mushrikun are people
who associate partners with Allah,
will abide in the fire of hell. They are
the worst of creatures."
Jews, Christians, and polytheists are
the worst of creatures, according to the
Quran.
What about Muslims?
In Sura 3, verse 110, Allah says to
Muslims, "You are the best of peoples
ever raised up for mankind." So, Muslims
are the best of peoples, non-Muslims are
the worst of creatures.
Second important idea.
It's built into Islamic thinking that
when Muslims win a battle, it's because
Allah is on their side. When they lose a
battle, it's because Allah is punishing
them for some sort of disobedience.
The first major Muslim battle with the
Meccans was the Battle of Badr.
Muslims won and Muhammad proclaimed,
"You see, this is the proof. This is the
proof that Islam is true."
Sura 3 verses 12 to 13.
"Say to those who disbelieve, you shall
be vanquished and driven together to
hell, and evil is the resting place.
Indeed, there was a sign for you in the
two hosts which met together in
encounter, the Muslims and the
polytheists. One party fighting in the
way of Allah and the other unbelieving,
whom they saw twice as many as
themselves with the sight of the eye,
and Allah strengthens with his aid whom
he pleases. Most surely, there is a
lesson in this for those who have
sight."
Notice, the Muslim victory is a sign for
the unbelievers.
The next Muslim battle with the Meccans
was the Battle of Uhud, which Muslims
lost. And Muhammad proclaimed, "You see,
this isn't because Islam isn't true,
it's because Allah is punishing us for
something we did."
Sura 3 verse 152.
"And Allah did indeed fulfill his
promise to you when you were killing
them, your enemy, with his permission,
until the moment you lost your courage
and fell to disputing about the order
and disobeyed after he showed you of the
booty, which you love.
Among you are some that desire this
world and some that desire the
hereafter.
Then he made you flee from them, your
enemy, that he might test you. But
surely, he forgave you, and Allah is
most gracious to the believers.
So, Muslims were winning at first, but
then they broke ranks and started
grabbing the spoils, and Allah punished
them by making them lose.
When Allah is with you, you win. When
you're disobedient, you lose.
When Allah is on your side, he gives you
the victory. When he's not on your side,
you suffer defeat.
As Islam spread west across northern
Africa and into Europe and east all the
way to India, its victories were proof
that Allah was helping the ummah conquer
the world.
Third important idea, the caliphate.
Caliph is a successor to Muhammad. A
caliphate is an Islamic state under the
rule of a caliph.
For nearly 13 centuries, Islam had a
caliphate, an Islamic empire governed by
some degree of Islamic law.
Lots of times there were rival Muslim
groups fighting for power, and not all
Muslims in all areas were under the
control of the caliph, but there tended
to be one dominant Muslim empire being
run by a successor to Muhammad.
The first caliphate was the Rashidun
caliphate, which began shortly after
Muhammad's death in 632 and lasted until
661.
Then there was the Umayyad caliphate
from 661 to 750. This was succeeded by
the Abbasid caliphate from 750 until
1517.
Lots of caveats with that one, though,
because the Abbasid caliphs were
sometimes mere figureheads for other
Muslim rulers and they didn't have much
real power once the Mongols invaded.
But, after the Abbasids, we had the
Ottoman Caliphate from 1517
to 1924.
The Ottoman Caliphate collapsed in 1924.
What happened there?
Well, after decades of decline, the
Muslims allied with the Germans, never a
good idea in World Wars, against Great
Britain, Russia, France, the United
States, and others. The Muslims were
defeated. Great Britain and France sat
down with a map of the Ottoman Empire
and divided it up however they saw fit.
Turkey secularized and a couple of
decades later, after World War II,
Western nations decided that since the
Germans were plotting with the Muslims
to exterminate Jews in the British
Mandate of Palestine, Jews had a pretty
solid case for needing some small place
where they wouldn't be at the mercy of
jihadis. So, a tiny part of the Ottoman
Empire was set aside for the Jews. The
surrounding Muslim nations were enraged
about Jews getting a strip of land that
had previously been conquered by
Muslims, so they attacked.
And these surrounding Muslim nations,
much like the Ottoman Empire, lost.
This time, they were defeated by an army
of Jews. Multiple Muslim nations were
defeated by Jews.
How did all of this affect Muslims
psychologically?
Let's just say they didn't take it too
well.
Think about those three ideas I
mentioned earlier.
Muslims are superior to non-Muslims. And
yet, Muslims in the 20th century were
defeated over and over again by inferior
non-Muslims.
When Muslims win a battle, it's proof
that God is on their side. And yet, in
the 20th century, Christians, Jews, and
other non-Muslims were winning the
battles and the wars.
For 13 centuries, Muslims had a
caliphate. And yet,
in the 20th century, they lost their
caliphate, and there was nothing they
could do about it.
Caliphates had collapsed before, but
prior to the 20th century, when a
caliphate collapsed, it was immediately
or eventually replaced by another
caliphate.
There was just a leadership change from
one Muslim group to another Muslim
group.
But when the Ottoman caliphate
collapsed, it wasn't replaced by another
caliphate. It was defeated and divided
up by non-Muslims.
There have been efforts to revive the
caliphate, but
you can't put Humpty Dumpty back
together again.
Hence,
in the minds of many people in the
Muslim world, Islam lost.
Islam was defeated.
So, Muslim nations started modernizing
and Westernizing.
Even in places like Afghanistan,
women started dressing like European and
American women and going to college and
pursuing careers in engineering and
computer technology. Islam had lost, the
West had won. If you can't beat them,
join them. Time to be more like the West
and less like 7th century Arabia.
But, certain Islamic revivalist
movements soon came up with an
alternative explanation for why Muslims
were losing.
The alternative explanation was that
non-Muslims weren't defeating Muslims
because the Islamic ideas were false and
outdated. No.
Non-Muslims were defeating Muslims
because Allah was punishing Muslims for
disobedience and for not imposing
Islamic law forcefully enough and for
having corrupt leaders and for
tolerating heresy.
Allah was punishing the ummah for
disobedience.
Now, if Muslims were losing because
Allah was punishing them for
disobedience,
what was the solution?
All Muslims had to do was become
obedient and impose Islamic law and have
devout leaders and crush heresy and if
they did, Allah would restore his favor
and bless them to continue conquering
the world and subjugating non-Muslims.
In Sunni Islam, this view gave rise to
the Muslim Brotherhood and similar
movements ultimately culminating in ISIS
and in Shia Islam, this view led to the
Iranian Revolution.
In Iran, Shia clerics seized control of
the government so that they could run
the nation according to Islamic law.
They crushed disobedience. They beat
people and imprisoned people and killed
people all to win back Allah's favor and
restore his blessing.
They've been doing that for almost five
decades now.
How are things looking for the
hypothesis that Muslims are only losing
because of disobedience and that by
being more devout and forcefully
imposing Islamic law, the tides would
turn and Muslims would start winning
again?
How's it looking for that hypothesis?
Not looking good. The United States and
Israel just took out the leader of the
entire Shia movement.
Ayatollah Khamenei was Allah's agent for
cracking down on disobedience and heresy
and look at what just happened to him.
Shia clerics
have been running Iran for nearly five
decades and they just keep getting
weaker.
Their obedience hasn't restored Allah's
blessing. Their obedience hasn't helped
them win at all.
They're still losing and it seems like
they're on their way out.
In other words, their hypothesis that
Muslims were losing because of
disobedience and that obedience would
help them start winning again has been
massively massively disconfirmed.
Shias can still believe that Allah has
some plan for the future, but the longer
they lose even when they think they're
doing everything right, the more the
avalanche of apostasy is going to
accelerate.
But that's Shias. What about Sunnis?
Ayatollah Khamenei has been killing
Sunni Muslims for decades. He's killed
hundreds of thousands of Sunni Muslims
through his puppet regimes.
So, Sunni Muslims could look at the
assassination of Khamenei and think that
Allah punished him by the hands of the
United States and Israel for killing
Sunnis.
And there are Sunni Muslims who are
celebrating the death of Khamenei, but
for the most part Sunnis are losing
their minds online and throwing tantrums
about the United States and Israel and a
surprising number of Sunnis are calling
for unity with Shias in spite of the
fact that Sunnis and Shias have been
killing each other since the 7th
century.
Why are so many Sunnis upset about the
assassination of Khamenei?
Well, think about it. Khamenei has been
killing tons of Sunnis.
There are around 1.7 billion Sunnis in
the world and they couldn't stop
Khamenei because they're too weak.
Who could stop Khamenei?
The United States and Israel.
From a Sunni perspective, who should
crush the Shia regime?
Sunnis, but they couldn't.
Who's actually crushing the Shia regime?
Non-Muslims, both outside and inside
Iran.
Keep in mind, even though there are
Christians and atheists and Jews and
Muslims and so on in the United States,
Muslims tend to think of the United
States as Christian.
And even though there are Jews and
Christians and Muslims and atheists and
so on in Israel, Muslims tend to think
of Israel as Jewish.
In Iran, there are all kinds of groups
as well. There are Zoroastrians and
Christians and atheists and Muslims.
Most people in Iran are sick of the Shia
regime.
So, who's wrecking the Shia regime right
now from a Muslim perspective?
Christians, Jews, and other non-Muslims.
Definitely not Sunnis. Sunnis are too
weak
as they have been for a long, long time.
In other words, the assassination of
Khomeini is a huge reminder to Sunnis
that despite their numbers, they're
still weak and getting weaker.
The Muslim Brotherhood hypothesis that
Muslims were only losing because of
disobedience and that obedience would
restore Allah's favor is, much like the
Shia hypothesis, being massively,
massively disconfirmed.
Muslims are throwing tantrums because
they're looking around at the world and
thinking,
"If Islam is true, this isn't the way
things should be."
And it's suffocating their confidence.
And when Muslims are doubting,
they tend to compensate by pretending to
be more confident.
This is why you're seeing so much
chest-thumping.
But, make no mistake. Losing their
caliphate, being weak and helpless
before inferior creatures like Jews and
Christians, and seeing their alternative
explanation destroyed is causing lots of
them to lose hope.
It's eating away at them and they're
doubting their religion.
Of course, just when you thought Muslims
were out of alternative explanations,
Western politicians have handed them a
new alternative explanation.
Muslims lost their caliphate. They've
lost battle after battle, war after war
to inferior non-Muslims.
Their original alternative explanation
was that Allah was simply punishing them
for disobedience. But obedience hasn't
changed anything, so that explanation is
failing.
But now, thanks to Western leaders, lots
of Muslims are thinking that Allah has
other plans for helping them conquer the
world.
Allah is the best of planners and his
brilliant plan now is to use the fact
that Islam creates nations that no one
wants to live in.
So, the people in these nations try to
get out of there as quickly as possible
and move to Western nations.
Allah will use this process to keep
sending Muslims to Western nations until
Islam takes over major cities at first
and then takes over entire nations.
Muslims can only believe that this is
Allah's plan because Western leaders
keep bringing in Muslims and helping
them take over cities. So, oddly enough,
it's non-Muslims who are keeping the
hope alive.
If Muslims didn't have this immigrate,
populate, and subjugate strategy as
their new alternative explanation,
they would have nowhere else to turn.
So, now you understand why the
assassination of Khamenei by non-Muslim
nations is so traumatic to Muslims.
Their main explanation for decades for
why Islam is so weak
has been that they just needed to be
more devout to win back Allah's favor.
They tried that and it was a complete,
utter, total failure.
No matter how Sharia compliant they are,
they keep losing.
Islam is only impressed by strength, but
the ummah just keeps getting weaker.
Many Muslims will keep hoping that Allah
has some other plan, but other Muslims
will lose all confidence in the claims
of Islam.
Avalanche of apostasy accelerating in
It is backfiring.
It is backfiring. [music] This is the
power of religion. There's a reason to
it. Yeah? Yeah? Yeah?